in this morning's ion money the race to
complete the end of here financial
planning there just six weeks left in
the year to take action on your income
tax withholding and to meet critical
deadlines for retirement plans CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
here with the money moves to make before
December 31st that you're here tax day
is is months away yeah and you're
invited right I'm sorry but you know
motivation yes you're ready to go yeah
six weeks to figure out whether or not
you're gonna have a really painful April
or a good April six weeks that's it
first thing we want people to do is
check their withholding
how much did you set aside go to irs.gov
they've got a with holding estimator and
you might need to make an adjustment you
go to your boss and you say either maybe
take more money out before the end of
the year so I don't pay a big bill or
maybe take less money out and then I
have a little bit more cash flow for the
holidays but you've got to check it if
you're self-employed you should have
been making some quarterly payments to
the IRS you might want to start doing
that now so you don't get penalized in
April a lot of people take on a lot of
debt over the whole how could tax
decisions tax decisions we make now
avoid that 27 percent of Americans said
they're going in debt during the
holidays they're going to get into debt
and that here's what I think is
important and that's preventable that is
prevents elfin foot so here's what you
can do well I know your gift to me it's
gonna cost a lot I know obviously but
what you can do is if you change that
withholding right because a lot of
people say oh I'll go into debt I'll get
a refund I'll pay off the debt well what
if you adjust your withholding right now
you get more money in your paycheck
today you pay for everything in current
dollars you don't go into debt and then
you have a much easier first court of
year we also know that there are
millions of Americans who are still
paying off last year's holidays right
now yeah I don't know they're
self-inflicted I mean people have to
participate in the holidays they do what
they can I wouldn't blame people
necessarily people just saying but you
know one thing you bring up as a way to
help people out as a IRA conversion what
is that alright so one of the things
that becomes really tough to deal with
is that people get
on money they've saved for retirement
okay and so what you think about is this
money I put in an IRA or a 401k its
pre-tax it goes in there hasn't been
taxed but when I retire the IRS actually
has a rule that says you have to start
taking money out after age 70 and a half
it's called the required minimum
distribution and that rule actually
creates a lot of income for people
during their retirement and the amazing
thing is that can hurt you when it comes
to your Social Security benefits because
you can get taxed on those benefits it
can make Medicare more expensive so one
idea is to convert some of those old
IRAs into Roth IRAs you pay the tax
today and then you don't have to pay it
later and you're not forced to take that
income one note that I should make this
like the blaring warning signal if you
don't take your required minimum
distribution you're over 70 and a half
right and you don't take it the IRS has
a massive penalty 50% penalty on what
you should have taken I know I'm sorry
they're not like the IRS it's funny oh
come on yeah and by the way one other
idea here before the end of the year is
if you find yourself maybe you've done
pretty well this year maybe you've got a
side hustle if you want before the end
of the year the next six weeks you might
boost those retirement contributions
maybe one or two percentage points more
that will help your own retirement plan
all right Joe thank you very much